[موسيقى]
ساعات التلفزيونيه تشرد اسرار قصر باكنهم
صراخ ولي عهد جديد بوجه اخيه انتقادات
لاذعه للصحافه البريطانيه وبرود وعلاقته
نساء العائله ببعضهم وثائقي هاري وماجن
سلب العائله الملكيه الخصوصيه التي طالما
ميزت ثقافه الانجليزي
فجرها الامير هاري ملك لم يمضي على توليه
العرش واشهر قليله ولي عهد يصارع الحفاظ
على اهميه العائله الملكيه في العصر
الحديث
ماتت الملكه صاحبه اطول فتره عرش موت شكل
صدمه للبريطانيين رغم انه متوقع لملكه
عاشت 96 عاما
ايام طويله من الحزن وماتم ملكي مهيب
شهيده العالم ودهشه
وفي حضره الموت توحدت العائله الملكيه
ووضعت فضائحها جانبا
[موسيقى]
رحله الملكه اليزابيث لكي لا تكون شهيده
على عداء الاشقاء حفيدها الامير هاري
القريب على قلبها من جهه والمؤتمن على
استمراريه العرش ولي العهد الامير وليام
من جهه اخرى
شيرلز مانشستر
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
روميا بالبيض اكثر من مره ولكنها لم تكن
اسوء تجاربه كملك جديد فقد اعتاد الازمات
مثل منع الاميرين هاري وانجو من ارتداء
الزي العسكري في المراسم الجنائزيه وتعليق
مهام الامير انجوي الملكيه بسبب اتهامات
تحرش ومن ثم اتهامات بالعنصريه طالت عرابه
ولي العهد
التاريخيه هز العائله الملكيه البريطانيه
صحيح انها اعتادت على الفضائح والازمات
لكن فيما تتفتح سنه 2023 اولى صفحاتها
البيضاء على الملك تشارلز ان يكتب تاريخا
جديدا يحافظ فيه على عائلته من لندن عروب
عبد الحق العربي العربيه